[Music]
kendall jenner brought in her 25th
birthday
early with a halloween themed party
the supermodel whose birthday is on
tuesday
hosted her celebration at harriet's
rooftop a top one hotel
in west hollywood
the party's star-studded guest list
included her sister
kylie jenner dosiacat sweetie
travis scott cuevo justin bieber
hailey bieber and the weeknd
name a few it's really awesome to be
able to share that with them
kim kardashian and kanye west also
joined in
on the festivities as well as family
friend
paris hilton e.t has learned that
every person who entered the venue both
employees
and party guests had to have a rapid
covet 19
test with a negative result on site
before going upstairs to the party
[Music]
the stars didn't come to play when it
comes to their costumes
kendall set the bar high stunning as
pamela anderson
from barbwire dosiacats served
fierceness
as tyra banks and the weeknd spent
six hours getting into his nutty
professor
costume
despite the good time the guests had the
party hasn't been well received by users
on social media fans were quick to voice
concerns
about a lack of social distancing and
mask
this comes soon after her sister kim
kardashian
also received some criticism for the
pictures and
captions she shared of her 40th birthday
private island celebration fans accused
the reality star's post
of being tone deaf and insensitive to
those suffering right now
amid the global pandemic kim's close
friend
lala anthony who attended the
celebration recently shared her thoughts
on the backlash
to e.t i don't really think too much
about it i just know we live in a world
where
people are going to have something to
say about everything it's just
what it is there's something that's
going to be said about everything you
wear a black top you should have wore a
red one you wear a blue top why didn't
you wear
the black one it's just the world we
live in and i don't really get you know
too caught up in that i know what we're
all doing individually when it comes to
charities when it comes to using our
platforms when it comes to voting
when it comes to prison reform when it
comes to the millions of things that
we're doing to try to you know just
help the world in general and that's
what what matters to me it's not just
about
going on an island and taking a
beautiful picture i mean there's a lot
more
to what all of us do in our day-to-day
lives you know than that and that's
that's what matters i rather amplify
that side of what we're doing